- Good morning.
Welcome to your first session
of 2025 re:Invent
and the first senior leaders track session
at re:Invent ever.
So it is 9:00 AM, Monday
morning in Las Vegas.
You must really, really love AI strategy.
(group laughing)
So let's get started. My
name is Helena Yin Koeppl.
I am executive in residence for AWS.
So I'm a member of a small group
of ex-senior leaders who had run
and led transformation in our past life
as AWS customers.
Now we join AWS to share
experiences with people like you.
As for myself before joining a... Oh.
Before joining now I hear it.
Before joining AWS last
year, I led 26 years of data
and AI transformation at
four Fortune 500 companies
in global roles.
So today's session, a lot
came from my own experiences,
but also my past two years
of talking to hundred
of customers on their AI journey.
So how much have happened
in the past three years?
We have gone through from
generative AI assistance
to generative AI agents
and now agentic AI systems.
And as any technology revolution,
we are foreseeing multiplication
of productivity gains.
So as you can see from
steam engine to electricity,
to moving to the cloud
and the multiplicator is
getting bigger and bigger
and the time it takes
to get there is getting
shorter and shorter.
What about AI?
How much do we see
productivity gains should be
and how long does it take?
And we do hope it can be hundred folds
and it can take the shortest of time.
Because generative AI and
agentic AI should unleash many,
many productivity, huge bottlenecks.
For example, these are the
five productivity bottlenecks
the agentic era should finally unleash.
Number one, unstructured knowledge.
We have gone through
many, many eras of sorting
through data, labeling them,
a lot of them are structured data.
And finally we have
unstructured data in PDF files,
in emails and critical
know-hows in PDFs and people.
Answers vary by who you ask
and all of this now can have
a single sighted front door
via agentic AI.
To getting through that
institutional knowledge
and reduce time to expedite
and narrow compliance risk.
As an example, one of the
AWS customers Moody's,
it is a risk rating agency
and it takes a lot of time to actually run
through the analysis
and huge amount of documents
to analyze risk rating.
What we help was to build a POC with them
and reducing basically using
multi-agent workflow to reduce
that risk assessment analysis
from one week to one hour.
Let's calculate the
productivity gain here.
Number two, we know with agentic AI,
one of the key things it can unleash
and what we have been
talking about for years
and years was basically that segment
of one customer journey.
So we've been talking
about personalization,
we've been talking about
tracking true customer's
preferences across platforms
and finally with agentic
AI's ability of acting
and we are able to do so.
As an example, anybody here
who is not a Rufus user?
Very few, almost none, a few.
Rufus is one of the key
examples of agentic AI powered
and generative AI powered
shopping assistant.
And because it can aggregate
all of those reviews
and product information, personal habits
and person who bought this also about that
and all of this information together,
it's really make it much, much quicker
actually 4.5 times
quicker during prime day
for shopping and maintaining low latency.
And we are foreseeing huge amount
of value coming out from
Rufus creation for amazon.com.
And we have seen that not only
in shopping in consumer base
but also in highly regulated
environment like banking.
NatWest boosts their
click-through rate by 900%
and 2 million more higher
interest savings account
publications by using
personalized experiences
and recommendations.
So number three, decision
latency in complex operations.
Huge, huge amount of data,
again, unstructured sensor data
and all can be aggregated together
and leveraging agentic
AI to make sense of it.
Example, again, coming from
Amazon, we have a agentic
and generative AI
assistant called DeepFleet
managing the 1 billion robots
we're using in our warehouses
and really helping the
automation becomes extreme
and from handling troubleshooting
to route directing
and dynamically deciding
what is the best way
of passing the right
products into packaging
and shipping out.
Again, a lot of the agentic
AI usage we have seen
is in service.
In service management in the past
and I have experienced that
more than 20 years ago.
If you want a great customer
support, you go follow the sum.
You have three teams based
in three different continents
covering 24 by seven.
Now you don't have to do that anymore.
DoorDash for the 7 million dashers have
that agentic AI system to support all
of their inquiries from
how much tariff does
this product cost today
to troubleshoot, again to
question and answering.
So that is 3 million savings
in just supporting the dashes.
Last but not least, faster product cycles.
So built-in, learning fast
and really sorting through
that huge knowledge base.
And we see that in
healthcare and life science,
one of the industries
I worked many years in
and very, very difficult
because normally there's huge
amount of unstructured data.
One of the examples we
have is in Genentech,
which is Roche Group company
and we help their research organization
to automate 43,000 hours
of manual work augmenting
their researchers' work
and that's equal to five
years of time saved.
So all of these great examples
yet when you're reading some
of the headlines, 95% of
agentic AI projects seem
to fail to deliver measurable ROI.
And if you read true
and read in the details,
what it's really saying is
those 5% of the companies
who manage to really gain value
and actually millions, millions
of incremental value in productivities
and in business, new business models,
what did they do differently
is really transforming their
strategy and business process.
So what I'm talking about
today is stop steering
today's AI challenge with
yesterday's playbook.
There are some of the examples
of yesterday's playbook.
I'm sorry if the mic is a
bit, I mean louder and softer.
So yesterday's playbook.
As an example, number one,
when we are talking about such piece
of fascinating technology,
very often we ask ourselves
what can I do about it?
Instead of starting with
the problem to solve
and we are actually going
into and using a solution,
searching for a problem.
That's number one.
Number two, we don't really
rethink about business process.
We look at the exact process as before
and just find steps of automating
and only having incremental gains
and sometimes even slowing it down.
And talking about the experiences,
still we are breaking the
experiences down into silos.
Marketing does communication,
sales lead generation
and none of them actually
are working together
towards actually that same customer.
And there are more in terms of the how
and we've been talking
about yes AI can unleash
productivity gains,
but what we do is not to
retrain and redesign roles
but actually replacing people.
This is actually not the right approach
and especially not the productivity gain
truly the right thing to do.
We have been in terms
of organizationally
centralized AI community
and we will talk specifically about that
and of course data which is the new oil
but especially to oil that engine of AI
and we are still not
setting the data up right.
So many organizations who come to us
who I have experienced before
actually have come to
this inflection point.
We have been doing a lot
of experimentation in
the past three years,
many, many POCs but we
have seen an even ROI
and actually scattered of
AI spending by function.
And really the matrix is
how many AI projects am I having
rather than the outcomes?
And now leaders come to us
who are asking the right question which is
are we really backing the
right top three value pools?
Will this give us the defendable
competitive advantage?
How do we turn the incremental ones truly
into compounding gains?
And this is today what
I'm going to talk about.
How do we do that?
How do we actually have an AI strategy
and implement to deliver that?
So let's think about the true
flywheel of AI innovation.
Yes it's great, we have
a lot of experimentation
and it's great to learn
about the new technology.
We actually should actually
go back to improve one step up
to say where am I going to truly invest AI
and where is the strategy point
and the business strategy
that I can support really
makes a difference.
Start with the opportunity,
not the solution.
And then of course deliver it but quickly
and truly show value and ROI
and all the while at the same time,
building the right foundation.
So that is the new AI strategy playbook.
There are six chapters
I'm going to talk about,
how do you actually
define a AI north star?
Starting from the AI strategy
that mirroring your business strategy.
How do you reimagine business process
and personalized experience?
Then how do you actually build
that motorway not just about
technology or platforms
but truly about people,
both in terms of everyone
who are leveraging AI in your company
but also your AI organization.
So number one, let's
start with AI North Star.
The successful AI transformation,
the biggest mistake
organization very often start
is let's have AI strategy
and let's look into how do I leverage AI.
The right question we should be asking is
what is your business
strategy and how do I,
and where do I translate
the business strategy
into AI strategy?
I've talked to organizations who wants
to translate business
strategy into AI strategy.
What they do is listing all
of their seven year business
strategy and looking into
and wondering how do I do this?
How am I going to translate
that very high level
vision into a very detailed
AI roadmap?
The number one question is
you want to ask yourself
where do you have opportunity to automate?
Where do you have opportunity to innovate,
creating new product new services
and where do you actually have
that disruptive advantage?
So keep that three questions in mind
and still think about how
am I going to translate?
And the answer is we should
ask different questions.
Not the same question, not the question
that we've been asking
for the past 50 years,
but I'm going to introduce a new framework
which is called RiPPLE.
These are a new mental
model which help you
to ask new questions,
to translate, to define
the must-haves on where your
AI can play a role to create
that competitive advantage as
comparing to nice to haves.
Okay, so.
So number one.
R, R means rational pause.
Let's look into
where is truly making a
difference in your business,
where your and actually
the uncomfortable truth,
where are you bleeding customers
and where you are losing
revenue to your competitors.
So the existing market defended
and protect your competitive advantage.
And how do we ask different questions?
Here are the different
questions that you can ask.
So think about yourself
comparing to competitors.
Where are the nimbler
competitors serving customer
faster than us?
What are the high volume
decisions that costing us a lot
of revenue through delays or errors?
And that's your opportunity.
What routine work prevents
our best people from winning
new businesses
and where do we lack real time visibility
into customers or competitor moves?
So that's number one.
That helps you to define
where is this problem space
that AI could play a major role.
Number two, incentive mapping.
Incentive mapping is all
about realizing within these
organizations, we often talk
about organizational silos
and how our organizational silo created.
It's not just because we
are in different departments
or functions or even in SAP teams,
it's because our incentive
systems are not aligned.
So we should actually
ask different questions
to discover that.
So you have conflicting incentives across
different departments.
Where are departments measured on matrix
that work against each other?
Where do department silos prevent us
from serving customer better?
And what handle bottlenecks
and data process are preventable?
And if you're discovering
those opportunity space
and that's where we go
into the second sector
which is re-imagining business process.
We have another framework to introduce.
Number three, perspective divergency.
This is quite interesting.
We do know that we do have problems
that we try to avoid
because it's too complex,
because it's always, always been there
and we have tried to solve it for years
and we couldn't solve it.
But right now ask yourself differently,
what if you have a AI native competitor
trying to get into space?
A place I worked before
and I led AI product innovation before
and it's about it's legal space.
And legal space has many,
many years of labeled data
and we truly think that we
have the competitive advantage.
However, when we are,
and there has been quite a few successful
new entries with AI first approach.
At first they were small but
because they have the
valuable insights very quickly
generated with AI and generative ai,
at one point they're truly
becoming threatening competitors.
So where does it make them nimble?
Where does it make them
competitive and how can we define
and how can we actually
leverage our own, for example,
proprietary data to actually
become more successful
than them by leveraging AI?
So here are some of the
questions you can ask yourself
to identify that area you
want to (indistinct) AI
and you want to try with experimentation
and moving into production.
Okay, so you've discovered
some opportunities
and a next natural actually
important question you want
to ask yourself is not should
we actually use AI here?
Not just could we? And
that's very, very important.
That is the contrarian truth, right?
So you can ask your question
as the process come into question,
what if it is already the best fit
for the context?
If we introduce AI into this process,
could it introduce new risks?
What are the mitigation?
And especially when we
have perceived bottlenecks,
is it real or is it
actually misunderstood?
So all of this, think about your business,
think about in your area that not could we
but should we as well.
The opposite.
And very important question you want
to ask yourself is also, if we build AI,
if we truly invest into resources,
if we truly invest into this problem area
with actually transforming
business process,
can we build sustainable
competitive modes through AI?
Maybe it is, maybe we can truly create
that data that are unique
that competitors cannot
and will never have access to
and we can embed AI into
workflows, continuously learn
and record that not only
in institutional knowledge
that we've been talking about
which are yearly, monthly,
but actually daily, second
of the operational knowledge
and continuously training AI,
learning on your business,
customize according to your
business and your operations
and where's your knowledge,
where's your proprietary data
and it's eventually becoming true
that nobody else can copy
and that is your mode
that your is your continuous
competitive advantage.
Last but not least, how
quickly can you implement it?
That is so important, the
velocity of implementing it.
And if you can implement
it within two months,
within six months you might
be able to create 18 months
of advantage that nobody else can follow.
And that is where you should invest.
And if you identify that opportunity,
put sponsorship
and develop skills to execute
not only for prototype
but truly moving it into
production to continuously keeping
that gap between you and your competitor.
So with this RIPPLE framework,
the opportunity filter
workshop is your next step.
So use that to identify
these opportunities
but score each of the opportunities
by these four factors.
Impact on business outcomes.
By the way, don't forget
technical feasibility
and that would also impact
how quickly you can leverage
it and implement it.
Creating (indistinct) with it.
Strategic alignment and
innovation velocity,
we talked about the last point.
And then select the must
have to move forward.
So that is your map.
Let's talk quickly about ROI.
And we have been talking
about we need to identify ROI
for AI, not only just
for the past three years
but ever since that I
started working on AI.
You need to, one key learning I've learned
in past many years is you need
to set up observation in operation.
So not post facts that will be too late.
You won't be able to separate successfully
what is AI and what is not.
So there are five steps you can do.
You need to select the right value stream.
It really have result into
productivity differentiation
or new revenue streams.
You need to embed AI into
that flow but wire the data.
You need to have the
entire data flow identified
and separating AI and long AI and you need
to actually take those usages
not only just AI, no AI,
how long, which part,
what's the percentage
and run and compare and scale.
And there are some AI ROI
discovery methodologies
to put my analysts hat on a little bit.
So there's when you are running pilot
and you are able to isolate
where you're running pilot
and a place where have similar environment
and similar activities but without AI.
So what you can't do is test and control.
So the test is where you
have AI like AP testing
and the control area is where you don't
and you can very quickly identify
how much incremental you can create.
After post-launch
because you have embedded
data flow, you are able
to do AI attribution analysis.
And when you are ongoing
what you can do is actually
every single touch point
can be identified with the AI touch
and how much AI touched to
continuously optimize it.
So that's number one.
Business strategy to AI strategy.
That's your AI north star.
Now let's look at a couple
of deep dive examples.
Number one is we talk
about business processes.
If you really keep it completely intact
and only automate the separate
part of it, what we can see
and what we have seen
from many, many interviews
with customers is you
don't actually see a lot
of AI value creation.
What we need to do is to shift from
the separate keeping things intact,
completely sequential implementation
of AI into reimagining the
complete business process,
focusing on what is the
outcome you want to get
and rethinking about it.
Several organizations I've
talked to have come back
to say, "We tried that.
We did a workshop, we talk about
the outcome and everybody went away
to think about the
opportunities and redesign it
and six weeks later they came
back with Excel sheets.""
So how do we actually do that?
And what I will suggest is again
ask different questions starting
with the sequential
that you have right now,
which is using.
I have a example of due diligence.
Due diligence, just like
any complex business process
today is pretty sequential, right?
So you collect the document,
you have the initial review
and then you flag the issues
and then the issue go
through legal review,
financial impact review
and eventually you have
the risk assessment
and you basically can say,
okay, can I deal with it or not
and is it worth it?
And do we have to go back
to the previous session
and handle the exceptions there?
And it is time consuming
and due diligence takes six
to nine months in average
and when you are actually
should be moving forward
with that business value creation.
So another thing to think about is,
and that's why we should
not start with technology.
Very often when we are
transforming business process,
it's not just one piece of technology,
it's not just agentic AA,
it's not just generative AI,
it's not just okay let's use AI assistant
and make the process a little bit better.
No, if you want to reimagine
the process as often said,
don't start with the technology
and this is a key piece of it
because let's identify
exactly what we want to do.
What is the most important thing
and most time consuming thing
is actually to discover issues
in due diligence
and then think about way
of mitigating issues.
When you are thinking about that
and you actually reimagine this process
into a non-sequential process.
So number one is I need to inject
all the information I
have, all the documents
and then I need to do
sematic analysis to identify
that key clause that might be the issue.
So that's number one, right?
So you are already aggregating several
of the components
together, not sequentially.
And you can use generative AI for it.
And once the anomaly is identified
and you can use analytical AI to do
for example compare it with your ERP data,
financial impact analysis
and do the risk scoring.
So that's cross-referencing and valuation.
And additionally let's
say the issue you discover
is a vendor which
actually have a clause of
terminating the contract if
any (indistinct) happens.
So what do I do here?
You actually can parallel process
and going into several
agentic AI coordinated
by a agentic AI coordinator.
And so using legal processing agents
and using financial analysis agent
and actually human oversight all together.
So that's your agentic
routine which save time
by not doing it sequentially
and identify what could be
the most optimum outcome
and solution and then
sending it to ramification.
And by the way the ramification
itself can use agentic AI
to draft waiver proposal for example.
And human at the same time in the loop
did decide the action.
So all of this is to reimagine
and not to think about sequentially.
So we talk about the how is important,
how do we do this?
How do we take a
sequential business process
and ask different questions to say
how do we completely reimagine this?
And I have a framework
which is called BREAK
and these are the BREAKS.
Blind spot scan,
reframe constraints, economic dissection,
assumption audit and
Kaizen, the happy path.
So what is blind sport scan?
When you have a business process
which you have been using
for years, it's very hard
to just tell yourself, reimagine it.
One method is to ask why
and ask why five times,
and sometimes some of the
whys might be why not.
So as an example, this
is a actual example.
The step currently is manual approval
for order over $1,000.
Why?
Because we need to prevent
fraud, it's a big amount.
But why?
Because big amount are risky. But why?
Because we cannot verify
customer intent with that amount.
Why? Because we don't have real time data.
Hey, the question has already been flipped
and it's no longer a compliance question,
it's actually a data question.
And the last why is
because our systems are
not interoperatable.
So that five whys help you
to identify again the
business process problem space
where you might want to dig deeper into.
That's your blind spot,
which without asking the
whys you would just go ahead
and continues to do what
you were doing before.
Second, we very often
have that constraints.
And another idea of
reframing that constraint
is to challenge your process limitations.
Ask yourself what if I have zero latency?
What could I achieve with that?
What if there's zero touch?
Then what could I have achieved that?
With for example, AWS,
we ask ourself what if we have zero ETL?
What can we achieve that?
And so the very often a new way
of thinking new invention
and new reimagining of
business process starts
with ask you a question.
This is a limit that I go to
and how am I going to achieve with that?
And then ask how do I achieve that?
And that's how breakthrough happens.
Economic dissection.
There are yes today that you might think
this process is what we can do,
but what we don't think about is
what are actually the
costs, the actual costs
and value destroying elements
if I don't make a change.
So for example,
very often we don't think
about the hidden costs,
when we are thinking about
"Hey this is as much as I can do in terms
of delivering for example
ideas of just work out".
Is thinking about it's
normal to stand in the queue
waiting in line at supermarket
but the hidden cost of time consumption
and hidden cost of people
being frustrated actually
put the things down and never buy it.
So those are the hidden costs
and value lost that you
have with your customers.
Think about in your process where are they
and how can we solve it?
We should have a assumption of it
and it's about flipping the sacred cows.
And sacred cows are very
often again being used
as there are risks, there
are compliance issues,
but is it truly?
Every single approval process sometimes
it might be compliance issue
but it might be just
organizational habits.
Ask yourself this approval processes,
are they truly compliance needed
or are we just used to it?
And we have to go through the
hierarchy of the organization
and also manual quality checks.
I only trust human to do this step.
Could it be prevented?
Can it be prevented?
And which sequential dependencies
are actually requirements
and just because historically we have
always been doing that.
The last BREAK, the last one is K,
Kaizen, the "happy path."
In process engineering
we very often talk about the happy path,
the path which is the easiest
and which is 80% of the
time you go through that
and that's where you put it in.
But the new way of
discovering the happy path,
especially when you have agentic AI,
when you actually can parallel process
many, many different scenarios
and find the right one is
actually that thing just happen.
That thing just happen for a while.
The picture you're seeing right here,
this happens in Ohio State University.
They want to build paths
for the students to get
to their lecture halls
and instead of building it,
they actually let students
just walk across the grass
and identify the most useful paths
and then eventually build the routes
according to the the foot paths.
So that is observing
the actual behavior and
because agentic AI has the ability
of logging everything, reflecting on it
and identify patterns with memories,
you can identify the happy
paths and formalize it.
So kaizen by the way in
case you're not familiar
with is Japanese philosophy.
It is about, I mean some
of the enterprises
organizations actually use it
as well in their business strategy.
So it's about continuous step
by step small improvement
to get to a bigger value.
But that frequent changes
is informed by actually
what has happened in actual
work and experiences.
And the identical AI Kaizen
at scale, as I mentioned,
there's continuous observation
and continuous recording
and continuous reflection
and learning loop with agentic AI,
and there's policy refinement according
to the agent's observation.
"Hey this path and with this analyst steps
actually takes 20%
shorter every single time
and we should reroute to that."
So that is the policy refinement
which is continuously done
and is traceable.
And parallel experimentation,
instead of AB testing,
you have A, B, C, D, E, F, G
and many, many thousands going in parallel
and finding the right path
and finding actually truly
the experience people prefer
and the feedback is always
integrated including actually the
human managers of the agentic AI system.
So with the BREAKs, the next one,
when you want to implement, how do you do
from process mapping and
identify your today's process.
It might be sequential,
you might already have some
digitized or automated part,
but then use the BREAK analysis
to truly challenge your
limits and the the holy cows.
And then of all the
bottlenecks you identified,
prioritizing which one
makes truly a difference
and what are the dependencies
you have on them?
And then map it to AI
solutions as I mentioned before
and what you have seen in the
due diligence re-imagining
of the processes and what
AI solution could we use.
And eventually have the
implementation roadmap.
That way instead of just saying,
let's reimagine the business process,
you have a bit of structured
approach to help you to get
to the opportunities.
An example that I already been working
with a few customers and
is clinical trial process.
Clinical trial is when we bring a drug to
the market, it takes roughly
10 years and billions
and billions of dollars normally
because you have to go
through phase one safety,
phase two efficacy and phase
three in a bigger population.
And many, many people believe
that all of this needs
to happen sequentially,
because of course safety first
and then small population
tasks for the efficacy
and bigger populations.
What we don't challenge
ourself is can some
of these processes happen in parallel.
When you are preparing documents,
when you are referring to
what is in the market already,
when you're referring to the literatures,
many of this actually can
happen at the same time
and through trial and error as well.
So using similar mindset
we can rethink about
how do we redesign the experience with AI
because it is often very,
very similar problem,
which is the silo problem.
When you're rethinking about it, the way
of doing it is put a human
at the center instead
of to say marketing
needs to do communication
and sales lead generation.
This is the person that
you need to actually serve.
What is her need
and what does she want
during the entire process?
Agentic AI can help you with that
because it has reasoning, planning, action
and orchestration all done
at the background similarly.
So let's use a actual example.
Returning products can
be quite frustrating
for customers.
So when you are doing
that, I want to return this
and at the behind the scenes
AI can do it in parallel,
assessing the possibility of, I mean
by the way the purchasing
history is being leveraged
to identify hey,
does this customer always always
return the products she bought?
Is it valid?
And what has been done before
and what are the warranty?
Can she return it?
Is it within 30 days
after she purchase it?
And reason it at the same time
and getting all of the related
information needed and acts.
So if it's valid, if it's
still within her right
and let's process it,
let's update also the
inventory immediately
and let's arrange the shipping
and let's notify the customers.
All of this, imagine if
it's our original process
of processing the return is going
through several departments
and all of this actually are
done without going through
that silo and with actually that person
with this particular needs at the center.
And you need to think about
how are the possibilities
of dealing with it more proactively.
Okay, we solve a problem
with returning the product
but eventually if you put
the human at the center,
these possibilities of
thinking about proactively
of designing her experiences,
can I propose a new
product if it's a customer?
Can I actually deal with
the project guideline
before the person notice it
and let her know, hey, it is
approaching in three days,
what are you doing can be accelerated?
And if you are dealing with partners,
can you actually identify
the challenge from all
the arrow locks and the repeated problems
that you might have
or the partner might
have about this issue?
So to implement it, an idea
is again during a workshop
and mapping that event you want to solve
and identify the silos
and also the entire orchestration.
Think about how can I use it
to completely transform the experience
and without thinking about
sequential steps that I need
to go through if it's
human team handling them.
Example is actually again in Amazon,
the entire Amazon organization moved into
an new agentic AI solution called A to Z.
So instead of when I need
a vacation, I need to go
through HR policies, I
need to ask from my manager
and all this information I provided,
I just type in with the interface,
I need a vacation of five days
and all of this needed information
and are truly send it to me.
Okay, so this is a system
according to the policy,
you are in Switzerland
and this is what you can do
and you have remaining 15 days.
Yes you can take five days
of vacation right now.
So if we put for example in
this case employee as the center
there is HR manager, payroll, IT,
all of this departmental
silos are put aside
and truly think about
what needed to be achieved
with this human in the
center and every processes
and tools can be leveraged.
Now let's talk about how do
we actually work together
with AI for all of your employees.
First of all, not everything
should be given to AI,
whether it's agent or generative AI.
There are agentic AI
big problem spaces that truly deserve
to use a launch agentic AI.
For example, you have a clear objective
because that's what AI needs to achieve.
You have sufficient data truly available
and you have many decisions
but it is possible to reverse.
In Amazon we talk about
one way door, two-way doors
and two way door decisions
can be reversed back
and those you can give to AI.
And you can retain human control
and you should retain human control
in more strategic decisions,
relationship sensitive
decisions and novel situations.
And let's not forget
and high stake decisions
and one way door and
irreversible decisions.
And we need to think about also we need to
think about human AI manager.
It is no longer a task definer.
So what is a task definer?
Run this report.
You define what needs to be done,
but truly now when we're working with AI,
especially agentic AI, we
need to give AI the objective.
I want to achieve this,
please do the payment on time,
please help this customer
and according to the
policies, return this product
with the right way within the time limit.
So that paradigm shift of task dedication
to objective setting is our truly
true change of the mindset.
So human's role as AI manager requires
three competency, objective setting,
performance monitoring and
strategic intervention.
So the details of objective
setting for example,
what is the primary goal you want AI
or agentic AI to achieve?
And you set the goal
but you also need to set
what is the success criteria.
For example, CSAT scores,
for example, resolution time
for example, fast contact
resolution percentage.
So all of this is
potentially success matrix.
What are the constraints?
What are escalation triggers?
When do you actually need
to keep human in the loop?
And how often do we
review the performance?
Weekly analysis, daily, monthly?
And leveraging AI's memory.
And very importantly,
AI manager skillsets are different
from human manager skillsets.
And one true important skill
is actually learning agility.
Human managers.
When you're working with AI agents
and we always say that it's
actually whoever knows how
to best leverage AI is going
to become the high
performer in the future,
the best people you have.
What he needs to do is
actually be very, very good
as at pattern recognition,
as in how exactly is the
best way of leveraging AI
and combining with my team members
to achieve the objective the best way,
the best route identification
we talked about.
And also knows intuitively if
after working with AI for a while,
what are actually the
contextual interventions
human needs to very often do
and do not let AI handle it.
So that human AI augmentation happens when
human intuitively know when
and how best to leverage AI.
And those are the four key
skillsets they need to develop
and eventually is truly on
the job by working together
with AI system.
Now let's talk about AI organization,
the organization which will
enable you to launch AI.
We have the leader, we have
the organizational structure,
we have the innovation ecosystem,
and we have the talent system.
Number one, the leader.
Anyone here who has the title of CAIO?
It is truly becoming a
trend that organization are
hiring CAIOs,
people who they believe should
be leading the AI strategy
and telling the organization that
how should we best leverage AI.
That's great, but
sometimes we do encounter
one leader cannot scale
because a lot of the organization,
especially the organization
at the top, the board,
the C-suites are very
often also new in this.
They don't know about
what AI can or cannot do
and they don't know what is the right way
of making their organization
truly know how to leverage AI.
So one key thing about CAIO is
actually to educate, to orchestrate
and distributed AI fluency
and ownership across the entire C-suite.
And we see that is the most effective way
of CAIO leading the organization.
One person cannot scale AI strategy
and cannot make it successful
for the entire company.
And then the AI organization itself,
I have done and being tasked and done AI
or data and AI transformation
for four global organizations.
And the model I often
use is hub and spoke.
Yes, we do need many
things in the hub in order
to scale quickly for
the entire organization,
but we also do need spokes into
the other business functions
and into the other departments
to help people learn
and to help actually people who are facing
that business problems
and opportunities daily
to identify the opportunities.
But how big is the hub
and how big are the spokes
and how flexible
or permanent are the
spokes are the differences.
So I mean I have led AI
research heavy models
where the organization is
truly creating something
and doing research on that,
doing cutting edge research on that,
doing something that
which are the industry's
holy grail problem.
If you were to establish
an AI organization,
which is research heavy, by all means,
AI center for expertise needs to be big
and very often the spokes
into the other functions
are temporary.
Going there solving one particular problem
and moving back into the
center which is called squats.
And then another model of
hub and spoke is small hub
and bigger and more permanent spokes.
And those are very often
with AI heavy model.
When I was working for global
life science companies where
that commercial organization's
hub was actually
at the center, but many, many
of the markets have spoke
which are permanently there.
But most important thing is
how are you going to discover
and scale that AI innovation
and how do you actually multiply that.
And that is what I call
AI incubator model.
Whether you are hub heavy or spoke heavy
and having that ring,
it's really important.
Because very often successful ideation
and pilot of AI use cases
happen in the spoke.
But when people discover that
and even it's successful,
they have no obligation to scale it.
And in order to actually mobilize that
and motivate people to actually moving it
and finding opportunities
of reapplying it in other organizations
and then feeding back to the hub
to actually create
permanent products to enable
that fast scale is that ring
and that's your innovation ecosystem
and that is the incubator.
Whether it belong to hub
or belong to spokes, it doesn't matter.
We very often say this is
the true two piece team
with multifunctional team,
business subject matter experts,
but importantly also AI experts.
Having the right talents,
having a talents which have
that business acumen
on the right hand side
and problem solving skills,
but also AI functional skills,
the left side and balanced left
and right side is very, very important.
Whichever organization
hub or spoke they are in.
But what you can adjust are the balance.
So some needs to be left brain heavy
and you need a lot of
in depth AI engineering
or scientist skills or
some needs to be balanced.
Like for example, a very important role
of AI translator is about
problem space discovery
and AI opportunity identification.
So that left brain and right
brain needs to be balanced.
So from strategy to
implementation takes 90 days
and to think about that
whether hub and spoke
and which type of hub and spoke
where your people today are
and doing the assessment
and identify that fluency
program for your team
and whether it is increasing
their left brain part
or right brain part is can be done
following this 30, 60, 90 days roadmap.
Last but not least, data.
We have been fixing the base for years.
Who hasn't encountered some of these,
data warehouses, data lakes,
data lakehouses, data mesh
and data fabric.
What we need to think about,
what we need to identify now is
how can I actually build
a living foundation?
Because your AI foundation
should not be a cathedral
and should not be keeping
your head down two years
and building it, but really
having it as living city
and lay the pipe and continuously develop
because agentic AI unlike all
of the others from the past
do not need perfect data.
It can take the data, it
can improve on the data
and it can actually
continuously use data to both
enrich the use case but also
further develop your models.
And AI technology
evolution is accelerating
and as we know this is just some
of the examples in the past three years.
So what we need to do
in terms of architecture
is also keep it simple and modularized.
And that's where, for example, solutions
and platforms like AWS
AgentCore can help you
and keep the choices and do not log in
and give you production
grade of observability.
And we need to not only
keep responsible AI
and risk management in principle,
but also operationalize it.
Okay, so for the implementation,
again for the 90 days,
if you want to actually
think about Agile foundation,
these are some
of the implementation
roadmaps you can follow.
Start with one use case, create
that template and expand.
So these are my six chapters
of AI strategy playbook
and this are the summary
for you to take back.
So if you have, our time is up,
but if you have any questions
and feel free to approach me
after the session or
throughout the entire re:Invent
and enjoy the rest of your re:Invent.
You've been a great audience.
Thank you very much.
(crowd clapping)